- There was this girl I had a
huge crush on when I was a kid
and she wore this like
cotton candy perfume,
and every time I would smell it,
I would, like, think about her,
and then a couple years later,
my sister started wearing it
and that, that (bleep) me up.
(upbeat music)
- Ugh.
- This smells kind of lemony,
with a hint of rose.
- I'm not mad at that,
that smells kind of like candy I think.
- It smells like you
would clean with this.
- I don't know man, all
perfume smells like,
they smell like moms to me.
- You know in the bathroom,
when someone just blew it up
and they Febreeze it?
Kinda getting that hint right now.
- I feel like I could
smell this on a guy, too,
and still be like, "Alright,
this works for you."
- I can't imagine getting
a whiff of this at a bar
and being like, "Ooh, who's that?"
This is more like, "Oh
shit, mom came to pick me up
"because I got too drunk."
(upbeat music)
I don't know what gold
smells like, but this isn't
what I pictured gold smelling like.
- This one kind of smells
like marshmallows and vodka.
- Birthday cake.
- This one smells like Off mosquito spray.
- I could see a Kardashian
wearing this one, but not Kim.
It's like a Khloe.
- I could do without Gold, I think.
(upbeat music)
- Playfully spirited, charmingly fun,
a bubbly, floral fruity that radiates
a sunny and sparkling energy.
Basically just described me.
- It's like sweet and floral, it's like
a honey flower.
- Smells a lot like high school.
- This could be like a
really good air freshener
for after you make a shadoobs.
- I like this one, this is nice.
- Daisy, I think is the
perfect name for this.
It's just like a good walk in the park.
- If I were a girl, this
is what I would wear.
This is like Jewish girl from New York
is probably all about this shit.
(upbeat music)
- Now this one I like.
- I would be okay if my
girlfriend was wearing this.
This is a nice smell.
- I feel like she knows what she's doing,
like, in the bedroom.
And, like, at first, you're intimidated,
you're like, "I don't know
if I can keep up with her,"
and then she's like, "No, I got you.
"I'ma teach you."
- If you love taking Nyquil,
this is the perfume for you.
- If somebody wore this and
was hugging me, I'd be like,
"You smell nice, you smell good."
- I'm still at Daisy
level, but I hope some day,
I could be La Vie Est Belle.
(upbeat music)
♫ Jazz. ♫
- Tom Ford.
Tom Ford can do no wrong.
- (sniffs)
- Oh, that is, that is awful.
- What is that?
- No, get this one away.
Smells like a churro died.
- It smells like, uh, an Old Fashion.
- Like if an orange had an asshole.
- This one actually smells like a dude.
- Is it unisex?
I feel like no sex should wear this one.
- I'm not mad at it.
I think I'd wear this one.
I would wear this one whether
it was Tom Ford or not.
- Who would wear this?
If you're watching and you
wear this, I'm so sorry.
We can never be.
- You always notice when people smell bad.
You don't necessarily notice
when people smell good.
And so I think that's a good reason
to invest into a nice cologne.
To be fair, you could probably
just go down to Rite-Aid.
(squeaky sign swings)